reading all the things you say in
interviews and stuff you talk about what
a big fat like do you exaggerate what a
big geeky Doctor Who fan you were when
you were a kid to make it kind of a
better story
to be honest I probably underplay it
yeah no I was a proper full-on I had a
Tom Baker doll my granny knitted me a
scarf the works yeah
a lot of who fans in and uh there's too
many in for them all to talk to you so
one of them right is going to get the
opportunity to ask you the one kind of
burning question of what was that right
the one thing they've always wanted the
opportunity to ask Doctor Who right so
will you marry me
not that
and so to to whittle it down twill it
down because you do know a lot of this
so ask them ask them a really really
really difficult a really difficult it
has to be really difficult because these
people are look at them look at them
getting ready they're getting ready okay
go with an incredibly difficult one oh I
wasn't I wasn't ready for this okay uh a
really hard one would be
um
what was the name oh that's good already
who was the actor who for two weeks took
over from Fraser Hines when he was sick
oh my God I can't believe somebody knows
that no wait wait let me just checked is
he the only one no one else knows oh
hang on we have another one over there
any advance on here
another one at the top should we go with
that because he was first he was very
quick he was very quick we'll go with
him but just it's interesting three
people okay and he might get it wrong
I'm doubting it but he might
okay what's your name sir David David an
excellent Name
what was the name of the actor Hamish
Wilson
he's absolutely right whoa
[Applause]
this is very exciting now I'm so sorry
I'm sorry were you right yeah were you
right yeah
look at the sadness in that face
yes I wasn't sorry sorry let me just get
into there you're fine you're fine
you're fine you're fine you're fine
you're fine you're fine all right so now
David so there he is Doctor have you met
that dude before yes I've met David
before how are you yes where did we meet
before we met on Daleks and Manhattan
set oh okay remember the Dallas
Gatsby but Alex Take Manhattan yeah had
you won the competition no I didn't win
a competition why were you there
[Applause]
David it's not too late
now
[Applause]
David David this is it yes he's about to
be not Doctor Who anymore so the one
question you've always wanted to ask him
off you go well my first memory of
Doctor Who was John Perry and planet of
the spiders okay uh what was
uh Doctor Who
that's it
[Applause]
that's a nice gentle question all right
what was your first member don't you
um it was probably John Patrick turning
into Tom Baker well that was mine from
the same story yeah yeah
yeah
that's it excuse me excuse me
very greatly
what was what was your question uh I
wanted to ask David
um obviously he's just finished Hamlet
who's a better writer Shakespeare or
Russell T Davis
[Applause]
that's a question that's a question
what's your name Matthew Matt is a
genius
I think Russell T Davis is the
Shakespeare of today
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]